hello and welcome back it's a game
review my name is Caleb Denby and today
I'm going to be taking you through yet
another game from the Tata Steel masters
tournament and this is one between the
us a number one player the world number
two player Fabiano Cara Juana and a
Chinese player by the name of you yang
Yi Yu yang Yi a very strong 2700 plus
grandmaster and has been for some time
now and so we'll see how Fabi managed to
approach this game to create some
chances started with E 4 E 5 Knight f3
and Yu yang Yi plays Knight f6 now if
you know anything about Fabiana Caruana
you'll know that he has employed the
petrov to great success in his own game
and in his own games however you yang Yi
no newbie to the Petroff either he's
been playing this for some time now and
so it makes sense that he would do no
different against Bobby Bobby chose this
line with d4 black captures this EEP on
that white neglected to defend and now
after Bishop d3 hitting this night we
see d5 Knight takes e5 97 white simply
castles here which is a bit of a
sideline by Fabi the main move is simply
Knight takes t7 we see 95d takes e5 now
Knight c5 from black looking to pick up
this light squared bishop and we see
Bishop e3 from Fabi
now c6 from you yang you and f4 is
fabi's choice and this is a bit of a new
move from Fabi f4 so early on commits to
a lot you see a lot of beginners and a
lot of amateur players commit to f4 very
very early on but you should know that
it really does come with some downsides
one huge downside is that in any endgame
the second rank is going to be a lot
weaker with this F pawn on f4 the F pawn
provides a lot of shelter for this king
and for the other Kings side pawns from
f2 additionally you'll see this diagonal
also come under fire in a lot of
positions here by playing f4 so you do
have to be very careful when you commit
to this move
but bobby was looking for a fight and f4
is the move that you play when you want
to fight Knight takes D 3 black does
capture this bishop we now see g6 aiming
to control this light square before
Bobby pushes all the way through with f5
Knight c3 b6 looking to control the c5
square as well Rick a d1 Bishop f5
whoops I'm sorry Rick a d1 Bishop g7 B
for fighting for the c5 square Bishop f5
Queen e2 Queen c8 and we've kind of
arrived at our middle game position so
there are some features to this to this
position that are pretty interesting I
think Fabi definitely won the opening
battle here I don't think it's fair to
say the black is much worse here if he's
worse at all but Fabi kind of has all of
the ideas and it's especially
highlighted by his next move of course
black made a threat
Bobby plays h3 controlling this g4
square and now black gets castled so
what do I mean by saying Bobby has all
of the ideas well he has ideas on the
queenside
which we'll come to find out this
structure is not the most stable it's
it's open to to being poked at being
prodded and some weaknesses might come
out of it as well as the Kings side
popping has ideas of playing things like
g4 and f5 and going after the king so
with ideas on both sides of the board it
can be hard to balance for the black
player and that's kind of what happened
in the game Bobby started with g4 moving
this Bishop back to e6
and now after b5 Bobby is really looking
to attack this structure like I said
it's open to being poked at then b5 has
really moved that pokes pokes at the
sore spots in in black structure of
course if this pawn moves to c5 you're
simply giving up this pawn on d5 so you
yang he doesn't try to touch the Queen
side instead plays f5 himself looking to
concretely stop Bobby from expanding on
the Kings side with
is f5 break Fabi plays pawn takes f6 on
passant Bishop takes f6 and now Bishop
d4 is as fabi's classy choice here and
while it doesn't look like much by
trading off these dark-squared bishop
s-- as is done in the game you're left
with this bishop versus this knife and
this is actually not a comfortable
imbalance at all for black all it takes
is this one pawn stuck on the d5 light
square for this bishop to be
significantly worse than than this
knight on c3 and because of that black
actually made some concessions here
pretty early on i do want to mention a
tactic black cannot play the move c5
here of course if the rook were to move
out of the way and black could play d4
this will be very very advantageous
solving all of blacks problems putting
these pawns in dark squares and this
bishop would be powerful on the open
diagonal but white has the nice
Intermezzo Knight takes d5 and if you
dare to capture my rook i will fork your
king and queen so no can do on c5
instead we see pawn takes b5 with the
idea that now if you want to take my D
pawn I'll simply capture your knight so
you see pawn takes b5 and the knight
actually captures on this side so that
this bishop can't trade itself off and
now black has a few options to try to
maintain equality here one of which is
simply playing a move Queen c6 with the
idea being okay I'll have a worse Bishop
but I only have this one weakness on d5
I don't think it's enough for you to try
to win this is one way of playing but
this is a very very uncomfortable way of
playing it's one that you won't see
strong players opt for very very often
strong players hate having this
positional deficit you know they want to
solve these problems and get to a
position that they know they can play
with activity and play comfortably for
for a draw or or morph and so because of
that you yang Jia chooses this move
Bishop d7 which i think is a really good
choice
it does give up this pawn on d5 but it
solves the problem of this bishop and
white has to spend some time collecting
this pawn and
using his pieces so we see York takes d5
Bishop b5 rook takes b5 this Queen comes
in to c3 eyeing some weaknesses rook b3
defends laterally you see Queen c5 check
and maybe this is where he actually
missed his chance to equalize simply
queen d4 check threatens to pick up this
pawn and if white wants to keep it he
has to play a move like Queen e3 and
double rook and games are well known for
being very very drawn and I think you
gave me as excellent drawing chances and
this position is actually just a dead
draw it with good play but instead we
see Queen c5 check which does not attack
the f4 pawn so white has this option of
king g2 now after some maneuvering we
see rook e8 Queen d2 rookie for once
again hitting this F pawn this is kind
of the weakness and White's camp Rick f2
is fabi's choice over protecting this
pawn to free up the screen a little bit
queen c6 makes some threats
King G 3 steps out of these threats
simply rook c4 now eyeing the C pawn as
well but Bobbie is starting to organize
that's very very dangerous I was talking
a lot earlier about the weakness created
by f4 along this set our second rank
notably black also played f5 and in this
game that is the weakness that counts
the seventh rank is very very weak and
this is how Fabi manages to create
enough play to play for a win we see
Rick f7 trying to defend this 7th rank
simply rook d6 shakes loose this Queen
and after Queen c5 Fabi does finally
commits to a break here you saw that
both players kind of maneuvering around
their pieces but the fact of the matter
is as long as this weakness on f4 and c2
kind of stands it's going to be
difficult for Fabi to to mount enough
pressure to really create some
meaningful threats so because of that he
plays a pawn break and that pawn break
is f5 and this is the move that that
really shows fob
fighting probe in here by playing f5
you're trying to break up the remainder
of blacks Kings side and kind of go for
the throat and this is something that is
very very useful to use in your own
games just because you're up upon
doesn't mean you should try to trade
into an end game where you can use that
pawn to make a queen in this case Fabi
is using this pawn for its own moving
abilities he wants to use this extra
pawn to make it be known that it's on
the board and use it as an attacker and
that's a very very useful thing to do
pawns are useful pieces and can be used
as attackers as pokers to poke open the
Kings side here for white and that's
exactly what happens so after f5 we see
Queen e5 check King G to rook c3 rook f3
trades off one set of rooks and now
rookie 7 is blacks choice Bobby
continues with rook d5 Queenie 4 check
King g3 King g7 is blacks decision now
roof d6 makes a threat like I said using
this extra pawn as an attacker things
like f6 are always going to be
threatened now Queen e5 check and Fabi
does a very very mean thing and that is
hides is King on age 4 and this King is
surprisingly resilient on h4 you can
check from this diagonal but all of
these squares seem to be covered you can
check from this diagonal but like I said
this extra pawn is going to make that
difficult you can't really check from
the file due to the aged pawns in the
way so this King surprisingly safe on h4
and now unfortunately for black you
Yangyi caves under the pressure plays G
takes f 5 tries to regain this pawn but
now Bobby is simply winning with his
next move Queen h6 King comes to g8 we
see Rick d8 check rook e8 and now rook
d7 threatens a checkmate and after rook
d7 this gives Bobby the opportunity he
needs to trade into a technically
winning King and pawn endgame and that
is done via Queen g5
picking f7 and then collecting all of
the pieces on the e7 square and taking
this pawn and with this extra pawn this
is a very very simple technical win for
white we see King f6 King g4 King e5
King G 5b 5c 3 and here black actually
resigns plate could have continued with
something like a 6 and after f6 it's
very clear that this King will
eventually be further out of play thanks
to this extra pawn for whites you can
imagine even something like this where
white picks up this pawn and will be
cleaning queening with plenty of time to
spare you might have not been the
simplest win but it shows that blacks
position is really really helpless so
this is a very very classy game by Fabi
and shows you how to use an extra pawn
to your advantage use it as an attacker
don't just keep it in your back pocket
and this is a very nice win for the
world number 2 thank you very much for
joining me for this episode of game
review my name is Caleb Denby and I will
see you in the next episode